hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie today we're going to finish
up this footer I took the morning off to
watch my kids when my wife had a
doctor's appointment so I haven't done
much but I had one really good idea at
least it seems good now I only had it
five minutes ago so we'll see we kept
having some conflicts with the Styles
yesterday when we were working on this
footer so I I thought why are we even
keeping the old styles we took
everything off of this page so we don't
need any of them so I went in went to
the top of our main master template here
and I commented out all this ESS and
when I did that it changed to the footer
Abed all of this stayed the same which
which is good it should have but down
here in the footer I have a little
little difference here if you remember
we had a different font and we had a
shadow on it before and we had some you
know buttons this was stabbed more like
a button all these links so now this is
using the materialized Styles still
needs a little bit of work but now we
won't have to fight with all those with
all the styles that are there now what
this does mean is that we're not going
to be able to keep any of the elements
that we're there like intact as is which
is okay with me you know they're they
all needed to be redone anyway but I
think this will make things a lot easier
for us it'll be pretty straightforward
now when we try to do something with
with materialized it should work and all
we have to worry about is just any
customizations that we need to make on
top of materia
so today I'd like to get this looking
exactly the way that we want to we want
it to look I'm thinking two Pomodoro
sessions so two 25-minute sessions of
code in between we'll do our five
minutes of question-and-answer and then
we'll finish up with some question and
answer it should be about an hour and a
half
assuming we get the normal number of
questions and during that time what I'd
like to accomplish is getting these
headers to all be the same
and I'd like everything to be aligned to
the right these need to be buttons
according to basically this well either
you know what you know what I like
better on on a dark background like this
I actually like what I call the inverted
button so I probably didn't make that up
I'm sure I got it at some point from
somewhere but I I don't remember where I
got that term from so basically you if
you don't understand you'll see when we
do it but it's going to be just a white
outline of a button and you'll be able
to see the green behind it
so we're gonna do those buttons we're
gonna fix this so that it looks a little
bit nicer and then we'll double-check on
a few screen sizes how everything stacks
up that's not okay yeah so that's not
too much but it's going to be nice
especially for for those of you who
maybe are just getting into things with
CSS and aren't super confident with
doing things with CSS or maybe just
working with materialise so I would say
at a level of difficulty this one's
going to be like down at like a 1 or 2
you know it's going to be a really
beginner friendly stream but if you're
not a beginner you know please stick
around because we're still you know can
get into some more in depth
in the question and answer sessions and
there's always people asking questions
that are you know unrelated to what we
happen to be doing in this particular
stream so I see in just a few people in
the live chat so hey how's it going
thanks for joining us so I did schedule
this stream a little bit later than
normal so we have not quite as many
viewers as we normally do at this point
but that's probably my fault okay John
John Hanson says he's getting an echo is
anybody else getting an echo let me know
it'll be a few seconds because of the
delay but it shouldn't be okay I was
double checking to make sure that my
voice wasn't playing over any speakers
here I don't hear anything okay awesome
so we'll get started a few I switched
back to my main camera so so far I've
had no problems with this main camera
because I I had to restart my Mac
because it froze yesterday right when I
was about to leave it froze so I just
shut it down and got to it today when I
got into the office but the good thing
is since I had to restart everything
anyway I updated Visual Studio code I
updated Adam I updated about 10 packages
in Adam so I did a lot of updates that I
had been putting off so I guess that's
ended up being good and the camera works
now so I have my second camera ready to
go so I actually have it over on the
side sheets help bring it in to the shot
but in case this one freezes I'll just
bring the other one in and we won't have
to mess with it throughout the
throughout the stream okay so now we got
a little bit more activity here in the
live chat I see
Umberto's here Hey umberto I got your
your direct message on Twitter for
a day or two ago I'm sorry I didn't
respond to that
I checked it and then I didn't have time
to respond and then I forgot about it
but I just remembered it now when I saw
you so sorry about not responding but I
did get it so I don't want you to think
I'm ignoring you okay let me set my
timer we're gonna do 25 minutes of code
all right so first thing I think I want
to do is get these headers looking you
know kind of uniform right now this is
an h5 and these are h2s so these are
being pulled in from the content
management system and we hard-coded this
and what I think we ought to do
especially now that I see everything
without any styles yet you know from
with the old styles I think I'd like to
just hard code these as well I I don't
think that these things change very
often I know we talked about this
yesterday of things that don't change
often and I mean like aren't likely to
change more than once a year I don't
really have a problem hard coding them
because that's not it's not really a big
deal for me once a year to go in and
change a line or two hopefully this
entire site is redone in a year so I may
never have to come back in and change
anything but I don't want this to be an
h2 I don't want these to be as they are
I want them to have the proper classes
to make them materialize buttons we will
have to so they don't have that inverted
button style and materialize by default
at least they didn't the last time I
checked there yet they are always adding
new things so it's possible I missed it
but I do have some Styles that I've made
you know in addition to the materialized
styles that work with materialized so
it's just kind of a little add-on that I
use personally in my project so we'll
just have to find that from a previous
project and put that in but we're gonna
we're going to redo this
I think that'll just make things a lot
easier once we get that done then we'll
work on this down here all right so
let's go down the bottom I think
actually we should be able to get rid of
a lot of this JavaScript now so I'm
thinking it's fancy
yeah I'm just gonna comment this out
right now I will see if we get any
errors but there shouldn't be anything
on the page that requires this dis
JavaScript as we start adding in more
elements we might find that we're
pulling in something from a template
that that does need that and then we'll
decide what to do same way we have wait
a bit here for for YouTube I don't know
that we'll need that I'm not going to go
through that now you know we're focusing
on the footer right now but we should be
able it looks like we should be able to
cut down the length of this file
significantly so even though we're
adding in some hard coded things that
we'll add to the length I think we'll be
able to cut out enough that it should at
least even out hopefully be a bit
shorter than it originally was and if it
comes down to it we can always separate
these things out into their own
components if it gets too large so we're
looking at these two columns here so
this is our Center column and then here
we have our our last our right column so
let's get rid of these and I think we
will need to we will need to go into our
CS file so our C sharp file and get rid
of some some things some lines in there
or else just going to throw an error so
let's find that
you know like building a folder okay let
me let me grab this folder
so I see so I'm trying to find this
folder and I'm assuming I could just
drag it over here I think I can write
not see if I can just drag it here whoa
okay cool
I don't need these this this
okay
all right so we need to find find where
we were
there we go master pages so this is what
I was looking for
oops alright I got a call I gotta take
this call so I'm gonna mute my mic and
take this
you
all right sorry about that that was a
great time for the normal disclaimer
this show is just me doing my normal
work as a front-end developer I'm
employed at a small university full time
so occasionally I do get a knock at the
door or a phone call that I need to take
so the goal is just to show you what my
work day is like and maybe if you're
interested in front-end development or
you like me pretty much work on your own
as a developer and don't know what it's
like for other developers I thought this
might be kind of helpful to see me doing
my thing making mistakes trying to work
through it so that's why you know we
have interruptions like that and you
know I don't mind when it happens I
don't like if it's a really long
interruption I don't want to waste your
time but that one actually was somewhat
related to what we're doing so evidently
someone is has a link to some page on
the main website that from what is
described these are the words of the
person on the phone not mine that it it
works but it doesn't so I don't know
what that means but two two guys from
the IT department are gonna stop by my
office in about an hour and 15 minutes
and they said they think it'll be easier
if they could just show me which is cool
I don't even have to go anywhere so I'm
fine with that but anyway I don't mind
helping out with stuff like that
actually currently right now I'm the
only person that knows any web
development that has access to these
files so I probably am the right person
to go to for that in a few weeks though
there will be somebody else here working
full-time that will have access so it
won't all be on me okay so let's I just
so Philips just said in the live chat
can we do bad lip-syncing while you're
on the phone I'd have been hilarious
yeah so I early on when I was streaming
there are a few times when I get calls
and I just talked and everyone can hear
what I was saying and then somebody I
can't remember who it was but somebody
in a live chat was like you really need
to mute your mic in case like something
is said that shouldn't be said on you
know on YouTube for everyone to hear and
so that was a good idea so now I am ute
when I when I can when I when I remember
it because occasionally that happens
it's not like big secret things but
sometimes since some of the marketing
department sometimes we get information
before it's released to the public so
that we can prepare how we want to say
things you know get things ready so
occasionally I might know about
something before everyone else is
supposed to know about it so so I'm not
trying to keep you all out of my
business you know otherwise I wouldn't
really care but that's better safe than
sorry with that kind of thing anyway
back to the code so we use that that
footer so that mid content and right
content and we're just going to get rid
of all references to those in here as I
said earlier otherwise we'll get an
error because it's going to be looking
for those elements and it's not gonna
find them so now we've removed them from
this c-sharp file and we'll save that
and did we say if I'm not sure if we
actually saved this file so we may have
to get rid of them again okay it did
save awesome so I'm gonna refresh we
should see nothing in these columns now
and we should get no errors okay awesome
great so now what we need to do is set
up so we have our column in here and we
need to do an H 5 mu nu H 5 great
yesterday I had complained that it
wasn't Auto completing my my tags my
HTML tags and you all had charlie
who it was sorry I can't remember who it
was that old that said that Emmet is
available by default and vs code but
whoever was that was awesome
so thank you really sorry I can't
remember who that was not I'm usually
pretty good about that but anyway when I
did the update one of the things that
said that was in the new update was it
completed HTML tags now by default so I
was happy about that so let's bring up
actually I'm gonna do this on the other
screen I'm gonna scroll down here just
to see what was in here was supposed to
be in here I'm gonna pull that to my
other screen so I can copy and paste it
easily and then we'll we'll build this
out to match that that first column that
we had made up here
whoa do we want that to be all caps I
don't think we want that to be all Cavs
we'll see we'll see how it looks but
I'm just not sure that I want that much
text to be capitalized I kept waiting
for the auto refresh I'm just so used to
that in my other four objects whoa
that's weird I thought we had okay I had
added these classes on to this let's see
if I really want this I'm gonna add
these classes as well but now that I
look at it I'm not sure that I want this
so the light class is gonna make the
font weight smaller so I think it makes
it about 400 font weight and then if you
add the thin class that makes it 300 we
can double check that for sure but I'm
pretty sure that's what it is and that's
just built built-in to materialise let's
see how that looks so I found that okay
not bad so I found that I like how the
the light and sometimes even the thin
font looks but only on my Mac so I have
nice screens and it looks good when I
try to look at it on an older screen on
a Windows computer it looks terrible and
you can barely read the text so I just I
have to always remember that that before
I commit to a font weight I need to
check it on older screens especially for
I mean really for any site but if it's
an internal site I know for sure what
kind of screens most people are going to
be using because there's pretty much a
standard Windows computer we have like
lenovo's with the standard sized screen
and resolution that I would say like 90%
of the people here use so I can be
pretty sure of what they're gonna see so
we'll see we'll just make sure we
double-check that at some point I'm not
sure why we're getting
why are we getting that space
oh okay I had forgotten we actually have
an image that's going to show up here
I just haven't we don't have the right
source so see we have this image we
don't have the right source for it yet
so we'll just have to get this in here
so that explains the difference the
difference here which yeah we'll see
you'll see I don't know that we actually
need another logo down here now that I
look at it because we have this sticky
header we're always gonna have a logo
visible yeah actually let's take this
out you know that's one less image that
needs to load on the page and I think
it'd be an unnecessary image so if we
can remove it then great alright awesome
okay we're just going to put in just a
regular paragraph tag and then we'll get
to those buttons the buttons will be
kind of fun just to see how we can
adjust what comes with materialise and
just kind of make our own variation on
it so let me copy the text here oops
I need to remember how did we do this
with Emmet there we go I need to
remember to start using Emmet because I
think it'll be a lot faster than what
I'm used to
okay I just checked no beer said that
says I think it's John B is the one who
told you that visual studio code I met
by default I think you're right I think
it was John B I actually I remember it
now because I remember saying that John
B like officially had the the tip of the
day like the best best comment in there
something like that for telling me that
so anyway I don't I don't see John B in
here so might not be watching but if you
catch the replay thanks again John B
sorry I forgot that it was you but thank
you because that that is gonna save me
so much time
I'm sure once I get the hang of it okay
let's see and I want to change so this
should not be two hyphens obviously that
needs to be an M - so I'm gonna look I'm
gonna look up the code for that -
let's see
okay so we'll replace this with an M -
and you'll see I'll show you the
difference in case you're not sure
what's what's going on so all right so
I'm gonna zoom in otherwise it's not
really gonna be obvious and I'll pull
this over as well so if you you can see
on this one we have two hyphens and
there's click it's clearly to life as
you can see the space in between it
right here we have a real - all right so
that's what we're supposed to have here
so this was probably maybe copy and
pasted from somewhere or entered into a
WYSIWYG editor and it was probably if it
was copy and pasted let's say like from
a Word document sometimes if you put two
hyphens next to each other depending on
the editor it'll automatically switch it
to this - so I'm assuming that that's
something like what happened and when it
got copy and pasted it it stayed is the
- two hyphens I don't know but anyway
when we see something like that will
definitely replace it with the HTML code
for that and then one will make sure you
know they don't it'll render properly
okay let's get rid of this Center right
so you don't want that and we don't want
the center here either
and may as well just put in the next the
next part here and I'm just gonna copy
this paste it and then I'll bring in the
rest
and probably about out of time for this
Pomodoro session so if you got if you're
asking any questions I will get to them
in just a few minutes
and now that we have this in this just
at least give us a nice idea of how this
is going to look still don't have the
buttons and yet but you know we'll get
to that I may as well try to add them in
here until I hear the the timer go off
let's see okay let me do this image
though right is it button
BTN nah now I can't remember what it is
all right let's try it like I can't
remember it if I spell out button or if
it's BTN so we're about to find out
okay cool that was it alright so here's
the default style we're gonna go ahead
and I'm gonna make put another button in
here and then put the button in there
and then we'll change the styles to do
that inverted button that I was telling
you all about at the beginning of the
stream so this should give us all the
buttons we want there we go great okay
obviously they're not all gonna say
apply this will say donate this will say
visit right now it says visit campus but
I I personally prefer shorter button
text so I'll just put it as apply and
visit and then this will be I'll keep
this as donate it says support
Franciscan in the button right now which
i think is just way too much text for a
button
so we'll see I'm sure that my boss will
let me know if that's if I'm allowed to
do that or not at some point but get a
minute okay about two minutes left so we
can at least start looking for the code
that I need for this so like where did I
have the inverted button okay you know
what we did the inverted button on
project one so I just need to look at
I had project one all the code open and
Adam earlier today and I thought hey I'm
not gonna need this anymore right and so
I closed it out and here I do need it
again so let's just go to github and
grab that code and I'll shoot I'm still
my incognito window let me go on a
window where I'm still logged in and
I'll be easier to find it
okay see I react yep that's what we want
let's see if we can search great okay so
here's our button inverted styles so
let's grab these and I'm being able to
search your entire repository for stuff
when github is just amazing like it just
it's so fast okay yeah we'll just grab
this and this should be yeah it should
be fun and let's need to bring up our
CSS
so for now I'm just gonna save this and
I'm gonna apply this button inverted
class and see what that actually we're
gonna see what that does
first thing whenever we get done
question-answer so for right now I'm
gonna scroll up in the live chat up to
the top and just go down through and get
through as many questions and comments
as I can then we'll do another 25 minute
session of code and it looks like we're
gonna be able to get this finished in
within one more 25-minute session which
is great okay so John Hanson said at the
beginning of stream that he was getting
an echo turns out there were two YouTube
windows running at the same time so
alright problem solves I'm glad I'm glad
it wasn't some issue on my end because I
don't really know that much about the
audio or the like audio video end of
streaming so if it was a problem on my
end I would have had the - a lot of
research
no beer says hi Jessie how are you not
bad I mean honestly I have a serious
lack of motivation today but other than
that not too bad I had some bad news
about my wife from the doctor this
morning so that's kind of a downer
but I think everything's gonna be all
right she's gonna have to do some
physical therapy for a while
but the doctor thinks that she'll she'll
recover so it's really crazy that she
had major surgery a year ago and this is
still related to that surgery she's
still trying to get over so I feel
really bad for that actually the doctor
told her she thinks she has
post-traumatic stress disorder from what
happened and that like that is actually
causing pain for her in addition to the
physical problems so that's really
stinks I just I can't do anything you
know I can't I can't help her so oh I
know that was a lot of info sorry
usually when people ask how you're doing
they're expecting like oh I'm doing
alright how you going but anyway so
that's how I'm doing right now the
stream always gets me going like even if
the whole rest of the day I just don't
feel like doing anything
once once the stream starts and I start
talking to you all like at least for
that time period I feel motivated to do
something so thank you all for that for
that motivation and I can usually keep
the motivation going for a little while
afterwards so at least if I stream I get
something done that day something
productive done
okay John Hanson at some point says
never never say never when did I say now
I can't remember if I said never about
something let me know what I said never
about because I cannot remember at all
what I was talking about them gold asks
what editor are you using I'm sure you
got a response to that one yeah
definitely so it is Visual Studio code
let me flip over to that Visio code so
for the first two projects
I used Adam switch to visual studio code
for this project mostly because when I
months ago when I initially started
working a little bit with this project
things didn't display right the syntax
highlighting didn't really work well
with the c-sharp files and I had been
meaning to try out Visual Studio code
anyway so I thought hey let's just try
that I just assumed Visual Studio code
would probably handle it better and it
did so I I just started using it so I
think it's cool to show different
different editors as well because we
always have discussions about what
editor is the best so this would be a
nice comparison you know that way if you
haven't tried it out yet you at least
get to see it see what it's like and see
the differences
okay so rook asks that's cool
this person's name and the live chat is
rook and then their their avatar is
actually a rook from from like the
Chesky the chess piece of rook so anyway
that's cool
my son and I played chess and
occasionally so I enjoy a good game of
chess every now and then but anyway the
question is I saw in a previous video
test being done when pushing to github
what does that there's a lot of things
you could do that that do that in that
particular project I'm using something
called nightmare and if you check if you
check out that project so in that video
there'll be a link to the github repo so
if you check out the pull request where
we added testing so turn that Kevin
added that in pretty early on so check
out some of the early pool requests and
specifically it'll say like testing in
in the title of it I can't remember
offhand what the the PR number is but
Kevin went through a really nice
thorough explanation of what kind of
testing was being done how it was being
done and even some of the other types of
testing that we could be doing as well
so that explanation is going to be a
much better answer than anything I could
give you right now in the stream so I
would check that out for sure if you're
if you're interested in more and how you
know how we're doing that alright so my
timer did go off let me write down where
I left off at
[Music]
okay and let's go set this timer again
alright so we've already brought in the
CSS that we need for these buttons I
probably brought in more than I needed
but yeah I don't know that I need this
this gives us maybe we do I think we do
I think this is the one we want I think
we want the button inverted white this
one will give us a black border I don't
want a black border on the green if we
were going on on a white background this
would be okay I don't know what ended up
happening here but it seems like I named
these differently than I would normally
do in a project probably at some point I
needed to change him and I didn't bother
changing the class name because I don't
think this is really what yeah this
isn't what I wanted what I normally mean
by an inverted button so I'll tell you
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take this
out and I'm gonna put in instead I'm
gonna take out this white and this
should be what we want I think I can
double-check that actually I you know
what I made a mistake this would have
worked these are actually the same thing
it's just one as a white border when
it's a black border in any case we want
the white water one for here I don't
think we'll have any need for the black
border one so my mistake there at the
with that first one I just I I happen to
look at the color variable instead of
the background color and that messed me
up anyway let's just add in
class we may not even need but enlarge
down here so we'll get rid of that yeah
there we go I think we'll get rid of
this button large class because I don't
want really giant buttons down there I
want them to be kind of slim and we'll
just put in now I can't remember what it
was but inverted okay
and let's see what we get it should be a
white outline and white text there we go
great alright so now we have these when
you hover it just fills it up with white
okay not bad I think it's it's kind of
like more sleek then let's say if we had
this this you know very bright color
here and I would still say you know in
certain circumstances we might want to
do that but I don't like having this
bright color if we have lots of buttons
so we have two buttons right next to
each other than a third one not that far
away
I think it's overwhelming the accent
color which is basically what this is
the the accent color and I mean this is
my opinion here but the accent color is
only effective if you use it sparingly
it's supposed to draw the eye because
it's different and it's vibrant if you
use it too much it no longer draws the
eye because the eyes used to seeing it
right so you you lose whatever benefit
that you had from that accent color so
if you see right now on the page it's
used once the only time you see that
color at all is here at this call to
action so that's that's how I like to
use it now not to say you couldn't use
it anywhere else on the page certainly
you know as we scroll down this won't be
in view anymore you could probably use
it somewhere else without really losing
the effect but in general I tried not to
use it too often on a page okay probably
one let's let's put in the correct text
in here and just kind of see how it
lines up and I may want a little bit of
space between these two buttons they're
kind of close together otherwise it
doesn't look too bad
or you know essentially it looks how I
wanted it to look so whether or not that
looks bad
I don't know but
we I got down what I wanted to so we're
gonna have which one this was apply
visit and donates and if we can so I
don't want to remove this right now but
I think I do want to talk about removing
this with my boss because we're gonna
have this donate button visible here all
the time so we may be able to get rid of
this and then put something else useful
in here instead of repeating donate or
just leave it out all together and we
could have just two columns yeah I mean
I think well I'm certain that there's
something else useful that could go here
we don't necessarily need this yeah
let's put in let's put in a little bit
of padding and bring we use dev tools
for this just so that we can see
beforehand without having to do a bunch
of refreshes what we want to do so let's
see I'll do I'm sorry margin left I said
padding but I'm we're gonna do margin
let's just adding eight pixels I like
that let's see eight pixels looks good
to me
okay so we're gonna add in eight pixels
I'm just gonna do this
inline yeah I'm just gonna do it inline
if I find that I'm using this same kind
of pattern a lot then maybe I'll do
something else with it maybe I could
make it class I don't know I'll figure
something out if that happens but I'm
not gonna do it right now I think it
would
be overkill so let's say style and I'm
gonna have to remember not to do it the
react way have been been in react land
for too long and now it it's affecting
my basic HTML skills so what do we say
margin left and eight pixels it was it
was just so hard for me not to put curly
brackets in camelcase that and to put
comments around that lets verify that I
did that right okay great
not bad I think this this font size is
just way too small
I want to double-check and see what size
that actually is ooh
10 font size 15 that really man maybe
it's just the resolution on my monitor
but that looks really small like
definitely not 15 I want to see where
that's being pulled in
I I kind of like having the baseline
font size at at least 16 pixels
see what that how much of a difference
that would make
not a lot just a slight difference here
for most of the text the interior text
in this section we're going to use that
materialize that responsive font class
that they have but I think the footer
can be a smaller smaller font size all
right I'm gonna leave that for now I
don't have to think about the best way
to handle this you know because the
fonts being set at several different
screen sizes
let's just try it out right now I think
I'm a let's see I just don't want to
override too much so let's see what what
happens if we do HTML font size 16
pixels we'll save that and let's see
what it does
and what I want to do is shrink this
down and see if it if we're gonna don't
write everything and is it gonna look
too big on a smaller screen okay and
then finally I want to test to see what
this does is float X
so this is that responsive font okay
wonderful all right so that's perfect
that's gonna work for us we're basically
resetting so that we're at minimum were
always having at least a 16 pixel font
size but it's not messing up our
responsive font so that's good
some time with that okay now let's see
what else we need whoa I don't like that
oh I see what it's like that you know
what let's take instead of having a left
margin on this second one let's put the
margin a right margin on this one so
when it gets to when it stacks we don't
have this weirdness going on and also we
need some we need a margin between these
as well so let's just move this off of
here put it here and we'll change this
from left to right and then while we're
in here let's add actually let's just
take this off completely let's add a
margin
of zero right eight pixels bottom eight
pixels and then left zero pixels
I'm really glad that we decided to do
the footer now because otherwise we may
have to be like scrolling down a lot to
see it it's nice that the page is short
here so there's not a whole lot of you
know we don't really have to scroll a
lot okay that looks nice let's make sure
it still looks nice here
aha is it no okay
okay that's popping that up so I don't
think the best thing to do is just to
add add a bottom margin here that's just
a simplest way to solve this for now
so I think at least for me and this is
my viewpoint on things if I'm coming
into a system like an old system and
trying to make things better and it's
probably not even going to be around
that much longer then I'm of the opinion
that it's no it's a waste of time trying
to make things in terms of how you're
organizing your code and all that try to
make things like really like you would
if it was a from scratch project so a
lot of things reusable and easy for
other people to understand right like
this is just a patch up job you know to
to last us maybe another year until we
can have another site so I have very
limited time to work on this just until
October and then I don't know when I'm
going to get another chance to work on
it so since we're just trying to get as
much as we possibly can done that's why
I do I'll do stuff like this right just
some inline Styles here because this was
the fastest way to solve this problem in
a very straightforward way I'm not I'm
not really worried about whether or not
this is necessarily the technically best
way to do it or you know
organizationally the best way to do it
so another disclaimer there's a good
disclaimer these are not tutorials this
is not hey I'm doing it the best way
possible this is I have various jobs and
projects to do with different deadlines
this is how I'm getting my stuff done
these are the compromises that have to
be made because a lot of tutorials are
trying to show like this is the best way
to do it which is wonderful and I love
those tutorials but I thought what was
maybe lacking in in terms of videos was
videos of someone saying I know this is
probably not the best way to do it but
here's our deadline and here's all the
stuff we have to do so this is what
we're going to do now and if we end up
getting done early we can always come
back and fix it but for right now we
need to work because it's been my
experience over the last like five years
or so
projects is that clients just don't
always have the money for you to do
things the absolutely perfect way and
you have to make a decision
do I want to just turn down the product
the the client do I want to get this
finished do I want to you know how do
you want to do things right
I mean you I don't think it's it's
unique to what we do you know I'm sure
they're you know when you hire a
contractor to work on your house you
know he'd love to be able to put in you
know granite and marble and you know
really nice top-of-the-line everything
and that would look amazing we look
great in in their portfolio right but
not everybody has the money or the time
for that so I think it's the same way
with us right it'd be great if we could
work on projects and do everything how
we would want to do it you know
completely you know cutting edge doing
everything right but that's just not the
reality
so hopefully this shows a little bit of
my reality of how I need to work so I
know my other people might have you know
different opinions about that but I
don't know I'm just practical about it I
don't want you anybody to feel bad for
just doing the job you know getting
things done so long as it works I you
know I do want to say I'm not saying cut
corners and make something that's not a
good product I'm saying just get things
done without worrying about little tiny
details in terms of code organization
I'll stress over tiny details in the UI
all day right because that's the user
will see that all right but if I had to
choose between stressing every UI
details or stretching over the
organization of my CSS I'm gonna choose
the CSS that's user facing the odds of
another developer ever even editing this
code aside from me are probably less
than 1% right now so I'm not worrying
about it anyway so I've been sorry for
me going off on that but just wanted to
kind of explain
my viewpoint on that okay so what do we
need to do now I got all off-track this
we need to get this in a better spot
basically what I want this to I want it
to be over here on this side and then we
need to figure out what its gonna do
when we go to a smaller screen I don't
want it to do this kind of stuff I'd
rather have it be probably on top of
this copyright so let's give this a shot
I think I'm gonna structure this
differently so right now we just we have
this so we have this on s12 right so it
does stack eventually let's let's change
first of all I want to change this just
to see what it'll look like just with
this kind of minor change so we're gonna
switch it up and on medium screens we're
gonna go full width to twelve columns
and then on large we're gonna split it
up let's see how much space that gives
us to work with now
okay all right not bad I mean obviously
I want it reversed but okay so we're at
that point I mean all right here's our
two options I think we can either make
it so that they basically just always
stacked except on extra large screens or
we can extend these out of their
container so that we give them some more
space you know in particular like here
you know let's say we gave extending
them out here and gave them just like 16
pixel margin on both sides that would
probably be enough space I think I like
the first option so let's try that I
want to make sure I think that
materialized did end up adding in an
extra class like an Excel class let's
see if it works so we're gonna go large
and then X I think that's how they
implemented it for a while they didn't
have an extra large class and we you had
to just make it yourself and then it
finally got in to a pool request okay
that Excel is what 1200 pixels when is
that kick in I think it's
yeah
so we're still getting you know some of
this going on that certain screen widths
um I guess I'm okay with that
okay
yeah I think I'm okay with that but what
I need to do though is we need to be
able to flip these around so to do that
I want to check out
I made a class for an earlier project
that allowed the easily allowed you
without having to create a lot of extra
markup to flip at certain screen sizes
to flip the order around so I want to
check that out first to see if we can
apply that here it's been a while since
I've used it but it could save us a
little bit of time so we're going to go
back to github and I'm gonna go to I
think I showed you this project
yesterday and I don't think it's in the
u.s. markup I think it's it's long
before we we made this organization it
is so it'll be on my my repo profile
there we go
it'll be on my profile
Franciscan Square okay so in the
franciscan square site I think I had
this wow this is bigger than I thought
it would be uh-huh that's why I didn't
search I thought I could just scroll
through and find it hold on I think I
remember what I called it
order there we go
okay so
okay that's what I did
so I think I use flex
is that my timer Wow the timer went off
okay so the only thing that I'm really
gonna change
I don't want it is completely finish but
we're really close the only thing I
wanted to change now well there are
basically two things I want to make sure
that these are kind of on the same line
I'm not sure why they're not right now
I'll just have to check in dev tools and
see I probably have some sort of padding
on this or something so I'm going to
check that out get these on the same
line and then what I'll probably do is
just implement some some form of this so
what I need to find is where exactly I'm
using flex here so I'll just open this
site up in dev tools I'll check out one
of the one of the columns that I'm using
this on and just see what's what's being
applied to the parent containers and
that should tell me everything that I
need to know about that and then
basically what will happen is the order
property here will flip so that on large
screens
- no no I'm sorry on small screens so
this meeting you queries hang on small
screens if it has the class of order one
the order will be one that has the class
of order - the order will be - so what
I'll be able to do then is put and I
guess I could put it on here now and
then I'll just copy a copy over
everything so
so what one is this actually needs to be
ordered to you want this to come second
and that needs to be order one so even
though this should always be one based
on the markup what will happen is on a
small screen they'll flip flop so that
this one will be above that one okay
now let's let me check the time okay
yeah I definitely want to go to do some
questions now
I have you know I've some people from IT
coming over in about 24 minutes so let
me screw up get through some of these
questions
okay Tafari design says while Visual
Studio code is free unbelievable yeah it
is it better than sublime our Adam I
like Visual Studio code so far at this
point I think I like Adam better but
that's probably just because of what I
have set up in terms of my color scheme
and my plugins so assuming I would have
the equivalent plug-in set up for Visual
Studio code I may like that better I'm
not sure I just I haven't had it set up
yet so I mean it took me years to get
Adam to the point where I have it now
with all these different plugins and
things so I've only been using Visual
Studio code aside from the few times I
used it a couple months ago I've only
been using it for what seven days this
is day seven in this project so maybe
I'll get there with it in terms of
plugins and then it can be a fair
comparison
okay so John Hanson has some good
information with what I was saying about
font weight and how you know this is
really clean and easy to read right now
on my Mac but if I were to open the same
thing on a Windows machine it doesn't
always look so clear so John the saying
lightweight fonts light color on a dark
background generally it's hard to get a
clean font he says it's all about
Windows running browsers interpolation
there are CSS hacks but they don't work
in new browsers okay yeah that's been my
experience as well I've tried to use
some of the CSS hacks before it's kinda
it's like anti-aliasing something is the
CSS property I can't remember the full
thing now I always have to look it up
but yeah it doesn't always result in
what you want it to hey Sebastian's here
hey Sebastian how's it going
Sebastian says dotnet looks so messy or
at least this code yeah it's probably
just this code I don't really know this
is the only time I worked with dotnet so
I'm not sure but I mean this code is
kind of messy I can't say anything about
this I copy and pasted most of this into
this this part is actually my code but
one of the one of the things that's
going on that's annoying me right now is
this file originally was using tabs and
not two spaces for indentation and I'm
copying in code that was using two
spaces for indentation so my indentation
is all messed up and I don't I haven't
gone through and fixed it because I've
been made lazy by standard J s and
prettier formatting all my stuff for me
so yes it's definitely a little a bit
messy but then even up here like all
this stuff I did not do it this was way
more CSS and JavaScript than I would
ever import into anything
Nikki says do you work with Pomodoro
sorry I just joined oh don't don't be
sorry about that any any questions are
welcome yes I do work with Pomodoro so I
guess it wasn't visible so I have this
is what I use for Pomodoro it's just
really basic tomato timer calm you know
so I do my normal 25-minute Pomodoro
sessions between each we have 5-minute
break after four sessions do a 10-minute
break so it's it's a really nice way to
break up the work I find that that
5-minute break
allows me to think about where I'm at in
the project what I'm doing otherwise
it's easy for me to get stuck on one
thing I can keep trying to let's say
find a bug in this one place without
thinking of the other possibilities that
5-minute break allows me to step back
for a second and think one like is this
problem even worth all the time that I'm
putting into it and then I can decide
well maybe not maybe it should be put
off until later because it's not really
that big of a thing and there are more
you know high priority issues to deal
with or I could think you know what
maybe I should try this other place to
look for this bug or something so I
really like that aspect of it it's nice
you know organization it allows me to
see like at the end of the day I can say
okay I've done this many Pomodoro
sessions that's good for me if I haven't
done that many I can think what was I
doing and I you know if I look back and
say okay well I had three meetings today
all right I know what I was doing but if
I can look back and say I didn't have
any meetings today you know what did I
do like I don't know like I was it was I
just reading blogs about new frameworks
all day or something like so it's kind
of like a nice way to keep track of my
my productivity as well okay
cool yeah if anybody ever wants to know
more about the Pomodoro Technique and
how I track things so I do use that in
conjunction with Trello
just kind of give me estimates of my
projects I've gone over that before on
some of the streams but I'm definitely
open to going over it again
okay so here's a cool tip so no beers
saying with so with Emmet instead of
earlier I typed div like this to get a
div but he said I can just do what he
says I could have just done this and
oops wait a second
where'd he go just type dot and then
it's not working for me maybe I have to
change the setting or something but it
for right now it is not working maybe if
I just add a class like there we go all
right cool so nobody here was right I
just wasn't doing doing it right so if
you just type dot and then put your
class names
it'll just by default put a div in there
really cool thanks okay
okay there's some talk about different
editors and which ones are free or not
that I haven't downloaded at him in a
long time it's been on my machines for
quite a while maybe like a year a year
and a half ago might have been the last
time I downloaded at them at that point
it was completely free I'm assuming it's
still completely free sublime and this
is I'm just gonna summarize what was
going on here in the live chat for a
while it seems like you can use sublime
somehow for free but there's a paid
version as well I don't know what the
difference is between the two it seems
like brackets is also paid and Visual
Studio code is definitely free although
it was said that there seemed to be ways
around paying for things I'm not gonna
endorse that so that's entirely up to
you whether you want to do that but at
least officially you do need to pay for
brackets and at least some version of
sublime safari design asks if I'm
recording the whole episode yes so all
these streams are recorded and they're
available on free code camp just within
minutes after the stream ends I put all
the videos into one big playlist called
live coding with Jesse and then
sometimes I split out and I also have
videos from each project in their own
playlist I don't have a playlist for
this project yet but project two does
have its own playlist but usually the
stream is kind of at the top of the
video list since I do streams you know
on a ideal week I do it five times a
week so it's never really that far down
the list you can find one of these
strains
brian says show her some love I'm
assuming that came when I was talking
about my wife and and her doctors
appointment everything so yeah thanks I
mean that's really about all I can do is
show some love because I'm not I mean
medically it's just like you know
there's some things you can do like so
like cut out a lot of caffeine and do
the physical therapy and things like
that you know exercise you know but
that's a lot of basic things and I can't
I can encourage her but I can't I can't
do it for her
so hopefully hopefully everything gets
back to normal one day so I think I
talked about this on a stream awhile ago
so I'm not gonna bring it all up again
but about last November
last October my my youngest daughter was
born and my wife had a rupture when the
birth happened and it was it was really
really lucky that my wife and the baby
didn't die but she was sent home from
the hospital like the next day or maybe
two days later and they never caught
that it had ruptured even though there
was all this I'm not gonna go into
details but there were there was
definitely signs that something had
happened but they still let her go home
and so for like a month we had no idea
what's going on but there are all these
problems so just to cut to the point she
had to have really major surgery we
can't have kids anymore and it was very
traumatic for her so that's why we're at
now almost a year from from when that
happened and it's still she's still
having medical issues and you know
mental health issues so it's just been
really hard for you know I think she
thought and I thought too that you know
she'd be completely you know kind of
over this by now and and I think a lot
of other people thought that too so it's
hard because she's not really getting a
lot of understanding or sympathy from
people you know that are in the family
and around her because they all assume
hey well
you over this yet so anyway I'm sure
it'll be I'm sure it'll work out it's
just going to take time
let's see safari design says I always
feel unmotivated when coding then my
motivation spikes all of a sudden out of
nowhere so yes it right around the time
when I was talking about my wife I was
also talking about my lack of motivation
today and yes it's a it I don't know my
motivation is weird I mentioned I
mentioned yesterday I'm not I think it
was yes maybe was the day before who
knows at some time recently I had
mentioned some like stuff about
depression and mental health so I'm not
gonna redo my whole speech about that
but I think a lot of my lack of
motivation is is twofold one well aside
from everything going on with my wife
which I'm sure is is impacting me I
really have been super busy and have not
even made an attempt to exercise in
weeks
that's definitely hurting me also I'm on
a new antidepressant medication and I'm
sure my body is trying to adjust to that
and so that's just some days are better
than others but right now it's like I
just don't want to get out of bed ever
so hopefully it'll all be better in four
to six weeks that's what they told me so
right now caffeine is is helping supply
some of the lack of motivation John
Hanson says all the best wishes to your
wife's recovery thank you I really
appreciate that
okay John John Hanson clarified so a
couple minutes ago I wasn't sure he was
referring to some time I said never and
I couldn't remember what I said so he
clarified and said you said never about
needing to go back into the new homepage
to edit it yeah you're right I should
not say never if I'm lucky I will never
have but realistically I'll probably
have to at least once when the URL
changes for the new student applications
for the prospective students to apply so
I will well assuming that this version
goes live before the application goes
live which who knows I don't know I
don't really know if we can get this new
stuff live before October when I have to
switch back to project one for a while I
think that would be really ambitious to
think that we could get it to the point
where it would be good and get approval
from everybody that needs to approve it
so it really may not be and so closer to
I don't know maybe realistically like
we're probably talking like December I
don't know
we'll say I'm hopeful it'll be earlier
than that but things tend to move really
slowly around here no matter how fast I
can build a site like it just seems like
for the big sites like this it has to go
through a lot of Hoops to get to get
approval our Sebastian says last year I
had a car accident where I broke my left
arm I had to have surgery to fix my bone
and now I have five screws my arm I
couldn't lift my fingers or hand for
almost three months and had no
sensitivity now it's almost fully
recovered still feeling weird but it's
at 99% function functionality I can't
lift hard stuff and my sensitivity is
not 100% but it's okay all right so
that's Wow and so that was a year ago
okay well that's I mean I'm sorry that
happened to you but I'm really glad that
you brought
up it's just the idea that I get at
least it's somewhat normal today
a whole year later not be fully
recovered as I like that idea I guess it
makes me feel like this is somewhat
normal and you know my wife will be okay
I think she'll be okay and the doctors
think should be okay
okay so Tafari design has another
question about editors since when
working at a company do they allow you
to use your own editors on the company
computer Roland says depends on the
company that's that's exactly what I was
thinking as well yeah so it does depend
here at the University when I first
started working here it was it was
difficult to get any anything on my
computer at first because so I didn't
have admin access to the computer on the
IT department did at some point I
finally got admin access because I
submitted a list of a lot of stuff that
I would need for development and at that
point I just came in and talked with
some of the people from IT and we got on
the same page about what I what my
development process was like what I
needed and kind of like how careful I
was gonna be about everything and then I
was allowed to have to have access the
condition to that was that I don't have
I'm not connected like to the main
network but in some of the ways that
other computers are connected so I was
fine with that because I didn't need
access to anything but just in case I
happen to screw something up which I
never have but it's possible that it
wouldn't spread it's a lot of other
computers so that's um that was that
with me so since that point I've been
able to use whatever editors I you know
I wanted the good thing about like Adam
and Visual Studio code is at least on a
Mac the download process and
installation actually doesn't require
you to have an admin password like admin
access I think it's probably has
something to do with it being electron
based because I've noticed that other
things that our electron base also do
that
so anyway technically I guess you could
get around it yeah but I have heard of
companies where things are really locked
down
I talked to a guy that's a developer he
lives in the same city as me but he
actually works up in Pittsburgh and he
said like there are some companies that
he his agency works for that are even
really picky about like what what
linters get used in your editor like so
it's you know they're picky right down
to really my new details in really in
situations where it doesn't make sense
that they're that picky so I I guess I'm
kind of fortunate and that I get a lot
of leeway to pick my tools and even
you've seen from project to project I
like to try out different things so not
everybody has it like that
john-john pink B says is there way to
upload to code pound a previously
downloaded code pen zip file I don't I
don't know I've never tried to do that I
heard about that being done so sorry I
really can't give you an answer maybe
somebody else with the live chat has had
experience with that but yeah I've I
really have no idea
okay
there's a there's still a lot of talk
about the the editors so I'm skipping
over a lot of the editor discussion
since I don't know we've have we have so
many discussions about editors I'm just
gonna I'm just going to skip
okay at some point safari design said
that I should split my screen so that we
could see the code and the design at the
same time I could probably do that but
it kind of depends like I when we're
when we're looking at like kind of a
more narrow screen that's fine but if I
want to get a wider view obviously I
can't do that so that's why I have
normally been flipping back and forth
and a lot of times I like to use dev
tools so I don't know maybe I could have
another desktop view that split and just
have that open like as a duplicate and
go to that off to think about it because
I do see some people in other videos
that make that work with the split it's
just always seemed to me like I don't
have enough space when I'm splitting my
screen like that so but I mean I could I
could try to give it a shot sometime
okay so if somebody I'm so somebody put
a message in the live chat that are in
other characters other than what I'm
used to reading so I'm gonna do a Google
Translate really quick to try to get it
into something I can't understand and
let's see okay so it looks like Mari
Sava so let me know if that's wrong but
this way I'm getting from Google
Translate so Mari Sava says hello Jessi
just sitting and watching your video
react project to day five I love it so
much that I wanted to say hello for a
long time and say thank you well you're
welcome thank you so much for saying
that I really appreciate that that
always makes me really happy when when
someone appreciates what I'm doing and
and get something out of it so thank you
thank you again for saying that Mari
also says it's 8 p.m. there so have a
good evening so maybe more you didn't
hear that my response to that maybe
maybe later maybe a more you can watch
the recording or something but let's see
Tafari design says Jessie's code is so
neat it makes my mind all fuzzy thinking
about freshly Windex glass Thanks I
don't I don't it doesn't look that neat
to me like honestly this looks a lot
more messy than my code normally is but
but like I said normally I I have it
automatically formatted for me so you
can't really I can't really take credit
for it before you design says is react
hard a lot of companies require that
skill nowadays
jonbi says hey Jambi hey how's it going
only way you'll find out is if you try
it see if it's difficult for you or easy
you might be surprised go check the
react documentation page they have a
tutorial for it
you
yeah definitely I try it out I think
when I first tried react I thought it
was hard just did I get my mind around
the concept and and the terminology and
things that was a little bit hard for me
but I watched videos of people doing it
and did some tutorials and then little
by little I got used to it
that's probably different you know for
different people depending on your your
experiences before trying to learn
reacts for me it was a little bit of a
challenge but now that I'm using reacts
I think I actually think it's really
easy to do you know do things and react
and I mean I've we've done just on this
dream alone you know we've used several
different things we've done server-side
rendered react we've pulled in data from
api's we've done we've used create react
react app and with react router so we've
done a lot of cool stuff on a project
I'm doing right now for for a course on
the side I'm using redux I'm starting to
learn react native and they all seem
really cool I mean I'm not gonna lie
Redux is probably the most challenging
thing so far for me but still I'm you
know I've only been exposed to it for
you know weeks yeah maybe like a month
it made probably over a month now but I
really haven't been able to dedicate
consistent time every day to it if I had
maybe I'd understand it a bit more right
now but even even with all that I think
I have a good grasp of things at this
point and I mean it hasn't really taken
that long so I say give react a shot
okay lost my place no Peter says Jessie
check the the right search input when I
clicked it it redirects the search page
yeah right now it does that so it
shouldn't do that I'm not sure what the
problem is so I am gonna have to check
that yeah cuz on the demo site it
doesn't do that so I'll figure it out
I'll get that working
nobody is said to try footer copyright
margin top 20 pixels okay I'll have to
give that a shot later on safari design
asks if I'm a freelance web developer no
well I mean I do some freelance work on
the side but my full-time job as a web
developer is at a university
I John Hanson said break the lines out
of their container it's easier and use
flex and no need for media queries okay
so I'll have to mess around with flex
with these and see if I can get that
working
okay Sebastian says in Visual Studio
code the bottom blue bar if you click
spaces cool and then using spaces yeah
too
okay so I have two now so it's not did
it automatically do anything I can't
even tell him that oh cool it looks like
maybe you do so that's definitely two
spaces now cool yeah that looks like it
did automatically change everything all
right
all right Sebastian thank you that like
it looks so much better to me now
awesome
that's how a design said Jessie don't
tell everyone all your business we
respect your privacy but also said I
also wish all the best for your wife as
well thank you I appreciate that yeah I
know I don't have to tell my business
but I don't know sometimes I feel like
if I talk about things it helps me but
it also helps anybody else that may be
going through something similar so you
know it's alright I don't mind talking
about that stuff I'm just worried that
you all don't wouldn't want to hear that
like you want to hear the code stuff so
I'm worried that I go on too long about
it so but otherwise you know I don't I
don't mind talking about that stuff and
you know especially to like about the
depression stuff I really don't mind
talking about that at all because I
think I think people need to talk about
that more and not be ashamed of it you
know like you know you get if you break
your leg you break your leg it's fine
everybody knows you break your leg and
they realize you know you're gonna walk
slow for a while right you might have a
wheelchair crutches right so if you have
depression it's gonna impact your life
and how how you can do things but if we
never talk about it you know people
aren't going to know people are going to
realize that that that's a legitimate
thing and it definitely impacts
someone's ability to do things just like
a broken leg would impact it I mean not
not just like but in a similar way as a
broken leg would impact physically how
you can walk you know depression would
impact mentally how you can interact
with the world do your job do I mean so
I don't know so I I think as long as we
don't I like the idea of being open with
it I don't like the idea that if you're
open with it you know you could be
discriminated against for jobs and
things like that as long as that doesn't
happen I'm all for people knowing just
more about it in general and I think we
could benefit so for me right now I'm
not gonna lose my job if I have
depression so I'm in a position where I
think I can talk about it you know to
other people and have it you know on
YouTube so so I am so I'm going to talk
about it
not all the time occasionally you know
and hopefully that couldn't help but I
mean this thing is mainly about code so
it's it's always gonna be at least like
90% about code if not more nobody said
oh that's so sad to hear about your wife
thank thank you I appreciate you saying
that Sebastian says I'm so sorry about
your wife hope she gets well soon
Sampson says same I appreciate
appreciate y'all Rohan says best wishes
for your family I really appreciate I
think thank you all I'll definitely let
my my wife know that you are we're
wishing her the best and everything
oh cool so Mari Sava was the right the
right translation of that so awesome
marisol this is Jesse you made my day
awesome I'm glad I'm glad that I could
do that I hide a B Shaykh says is is it
better than brackets for web development
so it's Visual Studio code better than
brackets I've never used brackets so I
can't say for sure but so far I like
Visual Studio code okay John B says on
the subject of being worried about space
with Visual Studio code you can toggle
word wrap with the option key and and Z
or on Windows the Alt key and Z let's
actually let's do that right now so I
don't forget so options cool I you know
what until you said that I didn't even
realize that I did not have word wrap on
because I've had it on by default and
Adam for so long that it didn't even
occur to me and that's a lot nicer not
thank you I'm learning a lot of cool
stuff about Visual Studio code I'm glad
I decided to use this for the stream
okay all right well I'm going to wrap
the stream up because the people are
here from IT check things out so thank
you so much for watching and I'll be
back tomorrow have a great day